Is there a rapper as
multitalented as Missy Elliott?
In 2019, Missy Elliott became
only the third rapper to be
inducted into the songwriters hall of fame.
Besides her own chart-toppers, she’s written
for Aaliyah, Mariah Carey, and Beyoncé
In 2019, she was honored with the Video Vanguard
award at the VMAs for her legacy
of culture-shifting music videos.
Let’s not forget Missy Elliott
the dancer. While some rappers
are still in their performances, she’s
leading the dance line from the front.
It’s Missy Elliott’s originality
and diverse talents that have made
her so influential on a new generation of rappers.
You can especially see the Missy influence in
artists like Tierra Whack who’s unique rap flows,
and mind bending music videos
have earned her critical acclaim.
In 2015, Tierra Whack tweeted “Missy
Elliott is my biggest influence!”
To which Missy responded “much love to
u Tierra Whack, I’m happy to be your
biggest influence, makes me proud following u.”